do you like a good horror movie with
extraterrestrial flavor and the tinge of
lovecraft do you also have a thing for
practical special effects ghastly
dismemberments
fountains of fake blood and a lot of
camp if you checked all of those boxes
amazon prime video just added a flick
available for rental that you need to
watch
immediately it's called psycho gorman
and it's unlike any horror comedy movie
you've ever seen
that last statement remains true even if
you're familiar with filmmaker steven
kostanski
co-director of 2016's the void or with
any of their similarly off-beat
productions from b-movie genre
powerhouse raven banner entertainment
as far as those films push the cinematic
limits of good taste
psycho gore man up to yante in ways few
films are set in tromaville would ever
dare it will come as little surprise
that kostanski indeed has ties to troma
having worked with the infamous
production house on several past
projects
including 2011's rioters father's day
psycho gourmand is just the director's
second solo feature however with much of
his previous work having been with the
astron 6 collective
and after his gonzo 2018 frightfest
leprechaun returns
it's safe to assume that kostanski is
categorically incapable
of holding back when it comes to pushing
boundaries if you want to see exactly
how far stephen kostanski goes in psycho
gorman
one look at the film's trailer will be
enough to prove it's a must-see for the
horror comedy set
the movie is a positively unhinged
adventure about a pre-teen girl who
along with her brother
uses a magical gem to resurrect an
ancient alien overlord
capable of destroying the universe
initially they use the creature in
service of their own childish whims
but that changes when intergalactic
assassins come to town and well the less
said about that madness the better
just know psycho gore man is the very
definition of a film that has to be seen
to be believed
even still many who have seen psycho
gorman are having trouble believing the
film's brazenly over-the-top action
and they've taken to reddit to discuss
the insanity poster occupy elm street
kicked things off by lovingly hailing
psycho goreman as quote one of the most
absurd horror comedies out there
it's nice meeting you it would be nicer
if you were dead
all right bye cash mclean i'm ready to
back the enthusiastic sentiment
proclaiming
i've been laughing about it for two days
straight the praise continued with user
wolf's blood a d
adding this instantly turned into one of
my new favorite movies i loved it so
much
it isn't just the bonkers tone of psycho
gourmand that's drawing raves in online
discussion
there's plenty of enthusiasm for the
movie's particular technical merits too
in fact those rubber monster vibes have
more than one commenter making a fairly
apt comparison
by calling the movie power rangers for
adults of course as one might assume
from the title
there's also so much gore that it's
basically impossible to discuss the
movie
without the conversation circling back
to that point again and again
and if reddit reviews aren't enough to
convince you you might be intrigued to
learn that professional critics have
been showing psycho gourmand some love
too
the splatterfest currently holds a
certified fresh rating on rotten
tomatoes with the review aggregator's
consensus stating that it quote
delivers all the cheesy midnight movie
goodness promised by its title
clearly psycho gorman comes with more
than a few hearty recommendations
of course it doesn't come without a
warning as occupy elm street writes in
their initial reddit post
of all the films i've seen in my
lifetime this one takes the cake for
not for everybody but if you want to see
whether it lives up to the hype you'll
have to drop
6.99 to find out as the film is
currently only available to rent
you'll just have to trust that for the
right sort of viewer psycho gourmand is
more than worth that poultry sum
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one